[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
is just a quick video going over the
brand new red nexus 5 a fairly
unexpected product in addition to the
black and white nexus 5 that we already
had available for months so what's the
difference what's new with this nexus 5
well literally only the color that's it
just a new design here no other added
value other than the additional color
choice now you might remember i actually
did a video on the black versus white
nexus 5 when they first came out because
they're actually made of slightly
different materials this red nexus 5
takes on the same materials as the black
one so it has that matte finish all the
way around and no glossy plastic so when
you're looking at this red nexus 5 here
it has the same contrast as that
stormtrooper one where the back is a
whole color uh including the dark nexus
logo and the dark lg logo it's all red
here
sort of a bright red cherry color i
would say and then you have the black
volume rocker on the left hand side and
the black camera ring on the back again
reminds me the storm trooper look has a
pretty nice contrast looks pretty good
and then a black power button on the
right hand side although the sim card
tray is actually painted red so it
blends in so then turning around to the
front of the phone you actually get even
more interesting you have a red earpiece
so the black nexus 5 has a black
earpiece the white nexus 5 has that
white earpiece and now the red one
continues that matching trend and
there's also that bezel so unlike the
white you can actually see the red of
the phone creeping around to the front
of the phone while you're using it that
might or might not annoy you but since
the paint extends all the way around
there
the bezel will appear a little bit red
on the edges now as many of you know i'm
a huge fan of the contrast between red
and black i've mentioned it in videos
before that i have a soft spot for those
colors and it's actually kind of hard to
show you the exact red color that this
phone is it's really bright in fact it's
actually called the bright red nexus 5
on the google play store and its color
is actually much brighter than a lot of
the red i already have and the things
that i own that i've shown in videos so
that might be the case for you too i've
compared it to a lot of other red things
around that i've also shown on this
channel but if you're wondering exactly
how red this will look in your hand i
found a red that the nexus 5 matches
most closely and that's the red on the
mkbhd youtube channel banner so right up
top of the channel here if you visit it
the color that the red most matches
closely uh is that banner red so there
you go i think that's enough for me to
call it the mkbhd edition nexus 5.
obviously google didn't go out and make
a phone a new color just for one thing
but they obviously actually i said it
was for valentine's day but now whenever
i look at the full nexus lineup i'm kind
of reminded of the mkbhd logo and that
for me is just priceless so there you go
thanks for watching this quick video if
you're interested in more nexus 5 videos
or coverage like this i've done several
on my channel already i have them linked
right below that like button i have the
full review i have the black versus
white nexus 5 the revisited what's on my
phone video it's all there so that's
been it thank you for watching and hey
maybe we'll see a green nexus 5 or st
patrick's day or blue or yellow that
would actually be pretty sweet thanks
for watching
talk to you guys later peace
[Music]
do
[Music]